All right, guys. So, I'm going to talk
about something that I frequently get
asked in one way or another uh within
the Discord especially, and it's, you
know, is this model good that I'm
trading? Can I learn your model or your
strategy or was this setup good? And
it's really a common misconception that
at least in my opinion that that a lot
of people don't understand. And it's the
difference between a framework, I would
say, and a trading setup or a model or a
strategy. They're two different things.
So, you know, regardless of what your
strategy is, right? Let's say that
you're looking for a break of structure,
you're looking for a liquidity sweep,
whatever that happens to be, it's not
saying that any, you know, those things
don't hold any validity to a sense or to
a certain degree. It's the simple fact
that they don't give you any read on
what market condition actually is. So in
the way that I like to view the markets,
it's more so based around kind of a
methodology or framework that you can
tweak and you can be you can apply any
degree of discretion to it. So um you
can apply it in your own way, right? Any
market, any preferred market, any time
frame, any kind of kind of style you
like. So instead of focusing on
short-term signals where a lot of people
will get granular and and open their
chart and and and look for what you know
whatever their their their model is or
their strategy is. It's more about
understanding you know the dynamics of
what a market is actually doing why it
is doing it what the condition is you
know where that condition changes right
and then from there you actually want to
go ahead and align yourself with what
the market is actually doing right it's
not you know most people when they open
a chart right they have for one they
have no system on how they want to
actually go about approaching that you
know they they they don't have kind of a
system where they go okay I'm going to
check this I'm going to check this I'm
going to check this I'm going to see
what all of these things are telling me
and then I'm going to come to a
conclusion. I'm going to see what hypos
I have going into the trading session
and quite frankly the vast majority of
people don't have anything like that.
The vast majority of people open a chart
and they go, "Okay, you know, we broke
structure here. I'm looking for a long
into this fair value gap and I'll target
swing high, something like that. Or I'm
waiting for a liquidity sweep, whatever
it happens to be." Well, there's a few
things that are wrong with that. For
one, you don't understand what the
condition is at that time. The way that
I like to read market condition is one
through a lens of auction market theory
and a way that I like to use it. Not
just, you know, the basic understanding
of what it is. It's how can you actually
contextualize those things. How can you
read all of those things together?
Especially with multiple different
references, giving multiple VWOPS,
multiple composite profiles, that kind
of thing. Um, so if you can't understand
what market condition is, you don't
truly know when it's bullish, when it's
bearish to any degree. you don't know
where where there's kind of clarity or
where where you can get a a clear read
on what's actually happening in the
market, what the condition is, right? If
you have no way to do that, it's never,
you know, you never really know if
you're on the right side of anything.
And that's where most people go wrong.
They say, oh, you know, my my setup
works good sometimes, but it doesn't.
Or, oh, the market's bad now. It's not
giving me my setups. Well, the problem
is you don't know how to read market
condition. That's the problem. And
that's what you know what we do or what
I do. It has nothing to do specifically
with a setup. It's not one setup I take
all the time. It's not one model I have.
It's absolutely nothing like that.
Right? That's not what we do. So I have
a way kind of in which that I'm able to
understand market condition. I'm able to
understand how important market
condition is at that time when that
condition changes, right? Where multiple
things agree or disagree with one
another, that kind of thing. And then
from there you align yourself with what
market condition is actually telling
you. So you do that in the form of
profiling right through kind of an AMT
lens. You do it with VWOP. So me
personally if I was to look at this,
this is Bitcoin. I like to look at VWOPS
and I like to look at profiles. So one
of the main things I do is I'll look at
multiple different VWOPS and understand,
you know, is this bullish? Is it
neutral? Is it not relevant to my
trading, you know, presently going into
this session? Is it bearish? You know,
are we at resistance? are we at support
right where are these relative to one
another okay and where can I trade and
at what point do I want to get out of
the trade to to where these things are
going to start to disagree or it becomes
too crowded and I don't want to trade it
anymore right so you know if we're to
look at this is yearly value right this
is developing year's value I'm just
going to disregard all the other prior
years but right so anywhere around here
developing year val is support right
developing year VWOP's going to be
resistance because we're below it right
so anywhere in there right If if we're
bearish below the level we see
acceptance back inside, right? You know,
that would be a bullish development
based on yearly value, right? And this
can be resistance till it's not until we
lose this level. It's going to be
support, right? And say we get above
VWOP, the next area it's logically going
to go to would be value area high, which
is the standard deviation above VWOP,
right? Same thing with with quarterly
value. You know, it's the same thing. So
you know we're b sorry we're bullish
against quarterly value right we start
to range here you know value area low
loses you know it loses support it's no
longer support here right that would be
a bearish development right and that
points to lower so I know VWOP's going
to be support previous quarter VWOP's
going to be support right developing
quarter value area low is going to be
support if we lose that it now becomes
resistance so I know you know within
there right this is going to be bearish
right of course there there's more
nuance stuff to this but Again, you get
an idea of how things kind of read. So,
if we're to look at monthly value right
now, right? We're we're we're bearish,
we're bearish, we're bearish, we're
bearish. You know, price trades back
inside of value. It's now bullish up to
this point, right? VWOP's going to be
resistance. So, I know anywhere within
there, right? I know this is going to be
kind of an area we're going to struggle.
It's going to trade up to. I know this
will be support until it's not. Okay.
Should we trade above VWOP, the next
level is value area high. Okay. So the
idea is that you can use all of these to
kind of form
uh you know form your hypos form come to
a conclusion going into the day going
into the week right and weekly will tell
you the same thing right so you can do
this with with multiple different tools
whether it's volume profile tpo vaps you
know any combination of those you can do
this anchored VWOP right you can do with
all of these so right resistance
resistance support support right And
that's it. So if you were to look at
this, right, you'd say, you know, we're,
you know, maybe we're neutral within
here, right? We're we're just, you know,
if you were to look at just value here,
right, or just this weekly VWOP chart
with price on Bitcoin, right? Given
that, you know, we're holding support
here. This is resistance. This is
resistance, right? That this is previous
week value uh prior week, right? This is
now previous week, but you know, it's
ranging here, right? This is neutral,
right? No side has taken control yet
just based on this range. So maybe given
that, you know, maybe there's longs
here, maybe there's shorts here, maybe
there's shorts here until we trade up,
right? Now that we're well above that
level, the next one to to maybe look at
up here, right? So you're trying to form
a story with all of this. So to simply
say, oh, I'm going to open the chart uh
you know, today, right? And I'm going to
long off this fair value gap. You don't
know that, right? Or what if you wanted
to,
you know what, what if you wanted to get
long, you know, on a break of structure
somewhere, right? I'm just I'm just
looking for something. But what you
know, what if you wanted to long at this
gap here, right? It traded up into
developing week VWOP and it traded
lower, right? So, you know, it's
probably not an area to to look for
longs because it's seemingly resistance
because it's, you know, price underneath
that level. So, things like that, right?
And then you can combine this kind of
idea by, you know, by looking at
profiling as well, right? So obviously
to you know get long around here. This
profile has developed up to this point.
But let me draw it back to where this
actually tagged.
You know I would actually include this
down here because we hadn't built value
out at that point. So value would look
more like this. Let me just drag this
down. This is your value area. Value
area high point of control value area
low. Right? So you know that this is
going to be support until it's not
resistance till it's not. We trade above
this is now support. Right? So given
that I expect this to hold and if it
doesn't hold right this is what you
could call a failed auction or a failure
above value right if you see acceptance
back inside right this now becomes
resistance right and then the next
levels you have are the point of control
value area low right so you want to
align yourself accordingly with where
the favorable trade locations are
relative to value and what the market
condition is right so if you got long up
here maybe that's okay right but it's
it's it's failing to trade higher you
know it capped it at rolling VWOP which
Just another another tool I like to use.
And with that being said, the condition
know it changes here, right? You were
bullish upon breaking it. It hasn't
continued higher, right? It now loses
that level of what was support. It
becomes resistance back inside of of
value, right? So that points to lower.
So you jump in short, which I shorted
here as well. Um, and then that being
said, you your next area to work with is
your point of control value area low,
right? And there was there was other
VWOP levels here. So if we look this was
June
June 10th is 6. So if we go back and
look at June 10th at 6, you know, that's
down here uh here maybe June 10th at 6,
right? It's it's monthly value area low.
It's also previous week value area low,
right? So you can see how you start to
form a story. So this is support, this
is support, and this is support, right?
You can see how they all overlap. So
these are support, right? You're
aligning yourself with, you know, with
with what condition could be shorting
here upon failing, right? This is now
resistance. Play it lower, right? And
this is now an area of significant
support. Of course, if that level is
lost, right? And you saw, you know, if
price traded through this level, you saw
this whether whether you know it does
this or it does this or it does this, it
doesn't matter. This is now resistance
until it isn't anymore, right? So to
just simply take trades,
you know, blindly off of levels, it it
just simply doesn't work. And that's
where people go wrong. Most people, I
want to preface this one more time
before we wrap this up, but most people
will open a chart and
they they have no way of reading what's
going on. You know, they'll open a chart
and let's say just disregarding any
levels here, maybe they see, you know,
okay, we're in an uptrend. This is
bullish, right? We have a big fair value
gap here. It's it's it's kind of a
support and resistance level. I want to
long around here, right? But to me, I
read this as, okay, we've traded back
into nine weeks of value. We found
acceptance above. We should continue to
trade up, right? We're also at monthly
value area high on VWAP, right? This is
resistance here. As much as we're not
above it yet, this this, you know, I
don't want to short here because,
you know, we traded back into value. So,
I'm actually long from here, right? But
if we do cap up here, you know, that's
resistance, right? This is support. This
is this is support right? So the next
logical target could be here could be
here. So I don't want to get long up
here at least, you know, right at the
high, right? But let's say we do lose
this level, right? You know, even
disregarding the longer VWOP levels
here, right? You know, we we capped
upside at monthly value area high, which
is resistance, and we traded above the
9week value area low, which is this much
older profile, right? I want to pull it
up, but it's this level along here,
right? So if you lose that, right, it
now marked a failure to trade inside,
right? and it capped at what you know is
resistance, right? So, do you really
want to get long here? Right? Of course,
there's some VWOP levels here. So,
maybe, you know, maybe we get a reaction
here, but you're trading against what
the market condition is, right? Like I
said, you want to align yourself, right?
It's it's not about the setup itself.
It's about aligning yourself with the
current market condition, right? And
what the story is actually telling you,
right? And then you know you're able to
understand condition relative to all of
these different things however you
decide to do it. It's completely
discretionary as much as you want it to
be. It gives you a way in which you can
read all of this stuff and then you are
able to take a discretionary approach
from there and and kind of boil it down
yourself. So you can use in my instance
I like to use multiple VWOPS. You can
use timebased ones. You can use daily,
weekly, monthly, quarterly, yearly even
longer from there if you wanted to. If
you wanted to to swing on a large scale,
you can use composite structure, you can
use tpo, you can use volume profile, you
know, however you like to do it, right?
Those are, you know, these are kind of
tools in which you can get an auction
market theory kind of lens applied to
them, right? And that's where you can
understand condition. And then that's
when you apply your trading model. So
really it goes, this is kind of how you
want to look at this in my opinion. It
goes
framework, right? And then you have, you
know, model, right? And then you have
your setup or I guess you can you know
you can say a setup and a model are the
same thing right but you need to right
you need to read market condition whoops
you need to read market condition then
you need to have you know what your kind
of contextual setups are that you like
to take right so I guess I guess these
are the same but you need to read market
condition then you need to understand
what your setup is you need to align the
setup with market condition okay so and
then all of these other tools you know
that you can use are supplementary on
top of that. So whether you use
daily open, weekly open, whether you use
a fib level, where you whether you use
uh imbalances and order blocks, whether
you use RSI, MACD, harmonics, you know,
whatever the tool happens to be, those
all like all of those can be used. All
those can be used as an edge, but on
their own, they're absolutely almost
useless or they're almost impossible
that to form repeatable edge because you
can't read market condition with those
tools, right? So, uh, hopefully that
clears things up. This is one thing I
get asked a lot about, especially like I
said in Discord. Um, and it, you know,
it comes down to to to understanding
condition and and just aligning with
strength and what, you know, recency and
condition tells you at the time. Cheers,
guys. Have a good one.